I'm like his Jessica padam before wasn't
sure if you were on of course she was
[Laughter]
Press that red cup
I saw the way Jessica lifted it up it is
empty just gaming
spilled everywhere okay you know what
you're [ __ ] fans better not attack me
[Music]
coffee all of your papers how is that
gonna be Jessica this isn't your first
interview of the day is it no I'm
serious you got a lot of muscles all
human fat yeah is this your first
interview of the morning yes you want
coffee all over stop talking just let it
where's the help yeah do you have
anybody your papers right there there is
a girl around she's wearing a grey
hoodie inches wow that's what that's not
good be more Jesse I'm a good audience
oh I'm gonna keep laughing about you
know let it go I have children
and I tell them not to get upset here's
the issue Jessica I beat the [ __ ] out of
them jessica is now gonna have to go
into all of her interviews today don't
throw out your press paper nose in you
need them for where you're going do you
think it's professional that's it
we only have the one copy no printers
here it's 2019 2020 you know printers
you're the [ __ ] are you guys doing one
napkin at a time son pouring water to
get the coffee smell jessica is a really
[ __ ] funny comedian everyone like you
you're one of the ones who
comic has kind of shitty thing said
about them but you're one of the ones
that everybody agrees is funny so same
with you well you know it's because they
just want to be on the radio show I
don't necessary yeah before the radio
show no one said anything and it's all
about chip no they do no no they do say
that well there are certain people they
say that like Colin and there are
certain people Dave Attell yeah
anybody that doesn't already know that
about Jessica is gonna be able to
experience it firsthand on Friday at
midnight on Comedy Central when talking
to myself comes out yeah oh that was you
calling it that's great yeah I was happy
that you are you're gonna laugh I I went
to edit it in the room in LA at all
things comedy and I kept watching the
clip in this dark room and every time I
turned around I had a tight bra on and a
velvet jacket and I kept thinking I have
a horrific back fat that's also a title
for the special wouldn't I've been the
best name that's amazing I would watch
it if you don't reference it vocally
throughout the special it's not one word
I knew but you're just watching and
you're like oh yeah I guess I guess she
does have some back fat that's okay
talking to myself is a good Thailand you
can always on your interview circuit you
can always talk about what you wanted to
call it as well and always talk about it
cuz sometimes you forget cuz there's
coffee on your sheet it's what you
remember yeah you don't really suppose
to be
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]